>> GIRLS, IT'S TIME FOR CLASS.
>> IT WAS BACK TO HIGH SCHOOL
FOR THE GIRLS.
THEY HAD A PROM FASHION SHOW...
>> OW! OW!
HOT MAMAS AT THE PROM.
>> AND A HIGH SCHOOL CLICHé
PHOTO SHOOT...
>> DON'T BE AFRAID TO GO THERE.
>> WHERE SAMANTHA
HAD A HARD TIME
BEING THE GIRL WITH
THE BAD REPUTATION,
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
11 GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪♪♪
>> I DON'T WANT
TO BE THE FAT GIRL.
>> THAT'S--THAT'S EXTREMELY--
SEE, I DON'T SEE MYSELF
AS A FAT GIRL, EITHER.
I JUST SEE CURVES, YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> BEING A PLUS-SIZE MODEL
IN THIS PARTICULAR COMPETITION
IS DIFFICULT.
BUT I DO ALSO HAVE WHITNEY
TO TALK TO.
NOT ONLY ARE WE BOTH
PLUS-SIZE MODELS,
BUT WE BOTH CLICK.
I NEVER, LIKE, REALLY LEARNED
HOW TO, LIKE, YOU KNOW,
POSE MY BODY TO MAKE IT LOOK,
LIKE, REAL GOOD.
>> LIKE, MAKE IT LOOK GOOD
FOR YOU.
>> YEAH, 'CAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
NO ROLLS, LIKE, HANGING OFF,
YOU KNOW?
>> YEAH. EXACTLY.
>> I MEAN,
ARE YOU SAD AT OTHER TIMES?
ARE YOU DOWN?
>> THE ONLY TIME I'M DOWN
IS 'CAUSE, YOU KNOW,
I'M MISSING MY FAMILY.
CASSANDRA REALLY MAKES ME FIND
MY INNER PEACE.
SHE JUST KNOWS WHAT TO SAY
AND WHEN TO SAY IT.
>> YOU WORRY ABOUT
PLEASING GOD AND YOU.
>> YES.
>> BE YOU.
I'M JUST BLESSED
AND I LOVE PEOPLE.
AND I KNOW IT'S A COMPETITION,
BUT I CAN STILL COMPETE
AND BE WHO I AM
AND BE, YOU KNOW,
NICE TO PEOPLE.
♪♪♪
>> (laughing) COME SEE.
>> IS THIS LOOK FOR ME?
>> YES, THE CHRISTMAS TREE
IS A VERY GOOD LOOK FOR YOU.
>> THAT'S ALL YOU RIGHT THERE.
>> I KNOW I'M PRETTY DIFFERENT
THAN MOST OF THE GIRLS,
BUT I HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY OF A LIFETIME
TO BE HERE,
AND I SHOULD FOCUS ON BEING
THE BEST MODEL I CAN BE.
>> (singsong voice) TYRA MAIL.
>> "WE CUT ONLY ONE LAST NIGHT,
BUT WE'LL CUT A FEW OF YOU
TOMORROW.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> OH, YEAH!
>> (cheering)
>> WE WERE BASICALLY
ALL WAITING TILL THE DAY
THAT WE HAD OUR MAKEOVERS.
I'M COMPLETELY,
COMPLETELY ECSTATIC.
>> THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT,
AND I'M NOT GONNA BE UPSET.
>> THAT'S MY GIRL.
>> (clicks tongue)
♪♪♪
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING!
>> AND WHERE ARE WE TODAY?
>> SALON!
>> WE'RE HERE WITH NEEKO,
WHO IS A REALLY GOOD FRIEND
OF OURS.
NEEKO'S ACTUALLY
EVEN WORKED WITH TYRA
SINCE SHE WAS 17 YEARS OLD.
HE LOVES RADICAL MAKEOVERS.
>> (cheering)
>> WHAT IS THIS?
>> WE HAVE MAKEOVERS TODAY.
>> I SAID WE'RE NOT EVEN
DOING THIS THIS SEASON,
BECAUSE EVERY SEASON
THE GIRLS ARE CRYIN',
AND "I DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO SEE ME
WITH MY HAIR WEAVE TRACKS OUT.
I DON'T WANT TO CUT MY HAIR!"
>> YOUR HAIR'S PRETTY LONG.
>> SO YOU DON'T THINK
MY HAIR SHOULD BE ONE LENGTH?
>> NO.
>> (crying) I LOOK LIKE A BOY.
>> I HATE SHORT HAIR ON ME.
>> HOW AM I GONNA GO BACK
TO MY BOYFRIEND?
>> (crying) I DON'T WANT
TO WATCH.
>> (laughs)
>> (sobbing)
>> I DON'T KNOW. DO YOU WANNA?
>> YES!
>> TELL ME AGAIN
THAT YOU NEED 'EM.
>> WE NEED MAKEOVERS!
>> HERE WE GO!
>> (cheering)
>> WE'RE GONNA START WITH JAEL.
SO WE'RE GONNA TAKE YOUR HAIR
LONG...
>> (cheering)
>> AND DOWN TO HERE.
BUT YOU'RE NOT GONNA
BE A BLONDE ANYMORE.
YOU'RE GOING TO BE A BRUNETTE.
CASSANDRA, TAKE THAT HAT OFF.
YOU HAVE A WIG
SEWN ON TOP OF YOUR HEAD,
WHICH I HAVE NEVER
HEARD OF BEFORE IN MY LIFE.
>> THE WIG IS SEWN ON LIKE SO.
IT'S SEWN ALL AROUND.
>> THAT WIG IS COMING OFF.
CLIP, CLIP, CLIP, CLIP, CLIP.
>> YAY!
>> BUT YOU'RE GETTING A WEAVE
DOWN TO HERE--
THICK AND CURLY AND WAVY,
BIG, BEAUTIFUL AFRO.
RENEE--STRONG FACE,
STRONG SHOULDERS, AND HAIR
JUST KIND OF IN THE WAY.
SO WE ARE CHOPPING IT OFF
YOANNA-STYLE, CYCLE 2.
>> (cheering)
>> YES!
OKAY, WHITNEY,
THIS WEAVE IS COMING OUT,
AND A GIRL WITH
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL PERSONALITY,
BEAUTIFUL SPARKLE,
BEAUTIFUL SHINE,
NEEDS A LOT OF BEAUTIFUL HAIR
DOWN TO HERE...
>> YES! YES! YES!
>> CURLY, WAVY, BIG.
DIANA, YOU'RE GONNA GO BLONDE
AND EVEN MAYBE
A COUPLE OF WEAVE TRACKS
SO I CAN MAKE IT
THICKER AND LONGER.
FELICIA, WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU
BANGS... (makes whooshing sound)
TO HERE
TO COVER UP ALL THAT BREAKAGE.
THAT'LL BE ALL COVERED.
BUT WE'RE NOT STOPPING HERE.
THIS IS ONLY ONE LAYER.
YOUR NEXT LAYER IS DOWN TO HERE.
DIONNE,
I LOVE YOUR SIDE PONYTAIL.
I THINK IT IS SO PRETTY.
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE
THAT WILL WORK FOR YOU, TOO.
>> WHAT IS THAT?
>> DO YOU KNOW THE SINGER KELIS?
>> YES.
>> YOU KNOW HOW HER HAIR
WAS SHORT...
>> OH, NO!
>> AND THE HEAVY THING
IN THE FRONT?
SARAH, WE JUST WANNA
SHAPE YOU UP A LITTLE BIT
AND ADD A LITTLE
DIRTINESS IN THERE,
'CAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT'S JUST REALLY FLAT.
JASLENE,
THERE'S A LOT OF LENGTH,
PROBABLY TOO MUCH.
WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO BRING THAT UP.
SO WE'RE GONNA WORK WITH THAT,
MAKE IT THICK, BODY AND FLOWY.
>> OKAY.
>> BRITTANY, YOU'RE A GIRL
THAT CAN ALMOST HANDLE ANYTHING.
LONG, WAVY RED HAIR,
BIG AND BUSHY.
>> (cheering)
>> AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST--
NATASHA, WHAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE GETTING IS
A VIDAL SASSOON-INSPIRED CUT.
IT'S GONNA BE
A LITTLE SHORTER IN THE BACK
AND COME...
(makes whooshing sound)
AND IT'S GONNA BE
CHOCOLATE BROWN.
>> (laughs) AAH!
>> ARE WE READY?
>> YEAH!
>> GIRL, WAIT A MINUTE.
WELL, WAIT A MINUTE.
BUT WAIT A MINUTE.
IF THEY'RE READY FOR A MAKEOVER,
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S TIME
THAT YOU DO A MAKEOVER?
'CAUSE MISS J. AND I
BEEN TALKING.
>> I'M READY FOR ANYTHING.
>> WELL,
YOU GOT SOME SCISSORS, J.?
>> YES, WE DO HAVE
SOME SCISSORS.
>> YEAH, WE--WE DO.
TURN YOUR--LOOK.
>> (screaming) OH, NO!
>> OH, JUST A LITTLE BIT,
YOU KNOW?
>> AAH!
MY BOYFRIEND'S
NOT GONNA LIKE MY HAIR!
>> (laughs)
>> LOOK AT THIS.
>> I-I CAN'T DO IT.
(imitates sobbing) I DON'T WANT
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
>> (laughing)
>> I CAN'T DO THIS!
AAH!
>> THAT CUT'S GONNA WORK.
BUT YOU GUYS ARE REALLY GONNA
WORK YOUR CUTS.
AND AFTER YOU'RE ALL DONE,
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A PHOTO SHOOT.
SO ARE YOU READY TO DO THIS?
>> YES!
♪♪♪
>> I'M GONNA
GO, UH, LIGHT BROWN.
>> THIS IS A NICE TONE, HUH?
>> THE COLOR--
IT REALLY BRINGS OUT
MY FACIAL FEATURES.
IT REALLY IS AWESOME.
>> WHAT'S UP, WANNABE.
>> MY HEAD IS BURNING
A LITTLE BIT,
BUT I'M NOT NERVOUS.
>> (laughs)
>> I WOULD'VE NEVER
IN A MILLION YEARS
GOT MY HAIR CUT LIKE THIS.
I'M LOVING IT.
>> I JUST DON'T KNOW
HOW I'M GONNA FEEL
ABOUT HAVING FAKE HAIR,
'CAUSE I CAN'T EVEN
CLEAN THE HAIR OUT OF MY BRUSH.
>> (chuckles)
>> DEAD HAIR FREAKS ME OUT.
>> JUST DON'T WASH YOUR HAIR
EVERY DAY.
>> I HAD MY HAIR DYED
A WHOLE BUNCH OF TIMES.
>> I'M SO EXCITED.
I'M SO GLAD
I'M GETTING SOME NEW HAIR.
I AM VERY HAPPY
THAT I'M GOING TO GET AN AFRO.
I LOVE HOW IT GIVES YOU
A LITTLE NATURAL FACE-LIFT.
I HANDLED IT AND ENDURED IT,
AND THE AFRO CAME OUT FABULOUS.
>> CAN YOU BRING
A LITTLE OF THIS
TO OUR PHOTO SHOOTS?
>> SO, YEAH, WE CAN SWEEP THIS
OR WE CAN SEPARATE IT
AND HIDE THE PART.
>> BY CHOPPING OFF MY HAIR,
I FELT LIKE THEY JUST
CHOPPED OFF ALL THIS ANGER,
RESENTMENT.
I FEEL LIKE A HAIR COMMERCIAL.
I FELT VERY, VERY GOOD.
>> THEY'RE CUTTING
ALL OF MY HAIR OFF.
>> WHEN WE DO THESE
KIND OF CHANGES,
THEY'RE MEANT
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR YOU.
>> RIGHT.
>> NOT JUST TO DO IT
FOR THE SAKE OF IT.
>> RIGHT.
I'M EXCITED.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE,
AND, YOU KNOW, I'M JUST GONNA
HAVE TO WORK WITH
WHAT I'M GIVEN.
>> I'M GETTING
NORMAL PEOPLE HAIR.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO ACT.
>> IT WON'T BE NORMAL.
I GUARANTEE YOU.
TRANSFORMING THE BEAST,
PART ONE.
YEAH!
(laughs)
>> I NEED MY MAKEOVER TODAY.
♪♪♪
>> THIS DON'T LOOK LIKE
ONE OF THE GIRLS
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO MAKE OVER
EARLIER TODAY.
>> WE'LL BRUSH OUT THE ENDS.
>> I THINK YOU SHOULD GO
VERY MIA FARROW.
AND IF YOU HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH IT, I THINK YOU SHOULD
JUST LEAVE MY SET.
>> I DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I CAME IN
TO MAKE THE BITCHES OVER,
AND I GOT THE MAKEOVER,
SO THE JOKE WAS ON ME.
>> (laughs)
>> TYRA ASSIGNED ME BANGS
AND A DARKER COLOR.
I THINK THIS IS PERFECT.
>> I LOVE YOUR SPIRIT TO DEATH,
AND I KNOW YOU GOT MODEL IN YOU.
>> I THINK THAT IT PROVES
ANY LOOK CAN WORK FOR ME.
>> TRY AND HANG IN THERE.
>> I AM.
(exhales deeply) OUCH.
OW! OW! OW! OW! OW!
OW.
I NEVER THOUGHT
GETTING MY HAIR DONE
WOULD BE SUCH A LONG ORDEAL,
BECAUSE I WOULD NEVER DO THIS
TO MYSELF.
>> THIS IS EVERYTHING
THAT I WANTED AND MORE.
LIKE, I AM IN LOVE
WITH THIS NEW HAIRSTYLE.
>> I LOVE YOUR HAIR COLOR.
>> I WAS BLONDE BEFORE,
BUT I DID IT MYSELF.
BUT I REALLY LIKE THIS.
THIS IS VERY--IT'S VERY CUTE.
I THINK I'M GONNA STAY LIKE THIS
FOR A LONG TIME.
>> (groaning)
IT TAKES ABOUT EIGHT HOURS
TO COMPLETE MY NEW FABULOUS 'DO,
AND IT HURTS LIKE HELL.
IS IT GONNA BLEED?
>> I FELT SORRY
FOR BRITTANY AND JAEL
TO SEE THEM HAVE TO GET
THOSE BRAIDS, BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT HURT LIKE CRAZY.
>> SEE HOW I'M TRANSFORMING
INTO NORMAL?
>> JUST STOP HERE FOR A SEC.
I JUST HAD A CALL WITH TYRA.
SHE AGREES THERE ARE THINGS
THAT WE'RE REALLY FIGHTING HERE
WITH YOUR HAIR.
THE BRAIDED WEAVE
ONLY COMES SO HIGH,
AND THEN WE HAD TO GLUE
MULTIPLE TRACKS IN.
IT'S NOT TAKING YOU
TO THAT ELEVATED LOOK
THAT THE OTHER GIRLS
ARE GOING TO.
LIKE, THEY'RE ALL STARTING
TO TURN INTO KIND OF MODELS.
IT'S KIND OF
BRINGING YOU DOWN A LITTLE.
I-I-I WOULD HATE FOR IT TO HURT
YOUR CHANCES IN THE COMPETITION.
>> RIGHT, BECAUSE OF YOUR HAIR.
>> YEAH, ME, TOO.
>> SO WITH THAT BEING SAID,
WE'RE GONNA
TAKE THE WHOLE THING OUT.
CRESHAN IS GONNA DO
A REALLY SHORT, KIND OF VERY
"ROSEMARY'S BABY" CUT.
>> JAEL--I FEEL SO BAD FOR HER.
SHE'S UPSET BECAUSE
SHE JUST SAT THERE
FOR EIGHT HOURS.
THAT MUST'VE BEEN SO HARD,
HAVING TO SIT THERE,
AND THE PAIN, AND THEN IT'S--
NOT EVEN BE WORTH ANYTHING.
>> OH, GOD.
♪♪♪
>> WE'RE SITTING IN THE SALON,
AND I SEE THE J's
TALKING TO JAEL.
SO THEY TOLD HER--
AFTER SHE HAD BEEN SITTING THERE
FOR EIGHT HOURS
GETTING THE WEAVE SEWN IN--
THAT THEY'RE GONNA
TAKE IT ALL OUT
AND CHOP ALL OF HER HAIR OFF.
>> OH, MAN.
AS MY HAIR WAS BEING CUT OFF,
I JUST FELT KIND OF TRAUMATIZED.
>> YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO WORK EXTRA HARD
NOW THAT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY HAIR
ON YOUR HEAD.
>> I HAVE NEVER
HAD TO GO THROUGH THAT ORDEAL
OF GETTING MY HAIR DONE
AND HAVING TO TAKE IT OUT
THE SAME DAY YOU GET IT PUT IN.
LIKE, THAT'S ABSOLUTE HELL.
>> THEN MAKE IT...
>> YOU LOOK SO MUCH BETTER.
YOUR FACE
LOOKS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE TEARS
FOR A MINUTE,
SO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT
YOU WANNA OWN IT.
>> I'M GONNA OWN THIS.
I DO LIKE MY HAIR.
I HAVE TO GET USED TO IT.
BUT I CAN ROCK ANY HAIR.
I'M A ROCKER.
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO DIDN'T MAKE THE CUT,
YOU HAVE ONE MORE CHANCE
TO MAKE IT UP TO ME.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> ALL OF US ARE GOING,
"WHAT? WHAT--WHAT THE HECK?"
AND I THOUGHT, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS GONNA BE
A MAKEUP CHALLENGE.
>> GOD, IT ITCHES SO BAD.
OW!
I'M REALLY NOT TRYING
TO COMPLAIN.
I'M REALLY NOT.
BUT... IT JUST HURTS.
MY HEAD HURTS SO BAD.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S FUNNY
ABOUT BRITTANY?
SHE WANTS SYMPATHY FROM OTHERS.
AND I'M, LIKE,
SO SICK OF IT ALREADY.
I WAS LIKE,
"ARE YOU CRYING AGAIN?"
>> CRYING ABOUT WHAT?
>> EVERYTHING.
>> OH, EVERYTHING?
>> BRITTANY JUST CRIES.
SHE JUST STARTS CRYING
AND CRYING AND CRYING.
AND SOMETIMES I JUST WANNA
SMACK HER AND BE LIKE,
GIRL, I WILL GIVE YOU SOMETHING
TO CRY ABOUT.
WHY YOU JUST BE CRYING
ALL THE TIME?
WHEN I HEAR A GIRL BOOHOOING,
SHE'S CRYING BECAUSE
HER BOYFRIEND JUST GOT SHOT,
OR WE WERE CRYING BECAUSE
OUR ROOMMATE JUST GOT SHOT
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T CRY
OVER EVERY LITTLE THING.
PEOPLE CRY ABOUT MAJOR STUFF
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR LIVES.
I TOLD HER HOW IT WAS
AND I SAID, END OF STORY,
AND I SLAPPED HER UP
AND I GAVE HER THE DEUCES
AND I WALKED AWAY.
>> YOUR STEAK'S READY.
(beep)
>> NEW MESSAGE.
>> Uh, give me a call
(bleep) passed away.
Give me a call.
>> OH, MY GOD!
(dial tone)
>> OH, GOD.
(dialing)
JAEL CHECKED HER MESSAGES
AND FOUND OUT
THAT A CLOSE FRIEND OF HERS
HAS PASSED AWAY.
(phone rings)
>> Hello?
>> WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> Uh, she overdosed.
>> OH, NO!
OKAY, I'M GONNA--
I'M GONNA CALL YOU BACK,
'CAUSE I WANNA GO OUTSIDE
'CAUSE I'M GONNA FREAK OUT,
OKAY?
OH, GOD!
(sobbing)
>> WAIT, HOLD ON, BECAUSE I--
THIS THING
CAN'T BE REAL RIGHT NOW.
>> (whispers) WHAT HAPPENED?
>> OH, GOD, NO!
THIS IS THE WORST THING
I CAN POSSIBLY HEAR
IN THE ENTIRE UNIVERSE.
>> (whispers) OH, MY GOD.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS.
(crying)
THIS DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> I'D RATHER NOT
BE DEALING WITH THIS SITUATION
THAT'S GOING ON IN MY LIFE,
BUT I THINK MODELING'S
A GOOD DISTRACTION
FOR ME RIGHT NOW.
>> WE ALL ARRIVED
AT THIS BEAUTIFUL GARDEN.
THE SUN WAS SHINING, THE GARDEN
WAS COLORFUL AND BEAUTIFUL.
>> I'M NOT GONNA, YOU KNOW,
GO TO THE HOSPITAL
BECAUSE OF A STOMACH BUG.
>> JUST, LIKE,
A STOMACH FLU OR SOMETHING?
>> THAT'S WHAT IT FEELS LIKE.
I... FEEL REALLY ILL.
I SORT OF HAD
SOME DIGESTIVE ISSUES,
AND I WAS THROWING UP.
>> NO, YOU PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO.
YOU'LL BE FINE.
>> HI, LADIES!
>> HI!
>> MY NAME IS ROXANNA FLOYD,
COVERGIRL MAKEUP ARTIST
AND COVERGIRL QUEEN CONSULTANT.
>> AND I'M CARISSA ROSENBERG.
I'M THE ENTERTAINMENT DIRECTOR
AT "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
>> OKAY, WE'RE IN
THIS BEAUTIFUL GARDEN,
AND COVERGIRL'S
SPRING COLOR COLLECTION
HAS BEEN SO INSPIRED BY
ALL THESE WONDERFUL BOTANICALS,
THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A MAKEUP CHALLENGE.
>> AND THE WINNER
OF THIS CHALLENGE
AND TWO FRIENDS
IS GONNA GET A SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE.
>> WOW!
>> OH!
>> (cheering)
>> BUT BEFORE WE BEGIN,
"SEVENTEEN"
IS GONNA STYLE YOU GUYS
IN THE PRETTIEST SPRING DRESSES.
♪♪♪
>> IT'S TOO TIGHT.
>> IT'S DIFFICULT BEING
A PLUS-SIZE MODEL
IN THIS COMPETITION.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE SURROUNDED
BY ALL THESE STRAIGHT MODELS,
AND WHEN WE DO CHALLENGES
OR WHATEVER,
THEN WE HAVE SAMPLE CLOTHES.
I'M JUST ALWAYS KIND OF WORRIED.
WHAT IF SOMETHING
DOESN'T FIT ME?
LIKE, WHAT AM I GONNA DO THEN?
>> NOW YOU HAVE TEN MINUTES
TO CREATE A CLEAN, COLORFUL LOOK
USING COVERGIRL'S
SPRING COLOR COLLECTION.
THERE ARE FIVE TABLES OUT THERE,
AND ON EACH TABLE
THERE ARE PRODUCTS--
FOUNDATION, EYES, CHEEKS,
LIPS AND NAILS.
READY?
>> YEAH!
>> GO!
>> (cheering)
>> WE ALL END UP
AT ONE TABLE TOGETHER.
EVERYBODY'S PUSHING AND FIGHTING
FOR THE MIRROR.
AND THEN, LIKE,
ONE GIRL TAKES OFF RUNNING,
AND SO THE REST OF US ARE LIKE,
OKAY, WE GOTTA HURRY UP!
YOU KNOW?
>> I DEFINITELY FELL IN LOVE
WITH THE COVERGIRL EYE SHADOW.
IT JUST WENT WITH
THE WHOLE SPRING LOOK.
>> ONE MINUTE!
>> I STILL FELT EXTREMELY SICK,
AND I TRIED NOT
TO LET THAT SHOW.
ESPECIALLY RUNNING AROUND
THE GARDEN,
I TRIED NOT TO THINK ABOUT IT
AND JUST RAN.
AND THEN AS SOON AS I STOPPED,
I WAS LIKE, OH, MY GOD,
THAT WAS, LIKE,
THE WORST IDEA EVER.
>> I HAD MY COMPLETE LOOK GOING,
AND THEN I THINK, OKAY,
I NEED A LITTLE MORE EYE SHADOW
ON MY EYES.
>> TEN, NINE, EIGHT, SEVEN,
SIX, FIVE, FOUR, THREE, TWO,
ONE.
>> TIME!
>> WHOA.
>> CASSANDRA, YOU WERE LATE.
>> I KNOW.
>> WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DISQUALIFY YOU.
>> I'M VERY UPSET
ABOUT BEING DISQUALIFIED
BECAUSE I KNOW I DID A GOOD JOB
ON MY MAKEUP.
I KNOW THAT I HAD A CHANCE
OF WINNING.
>> LET'S SEE WHAT YOU DID.
>> I SEE A LITTLE SOMETHING
HERE AND THERE.
WHITNEY, DO YOU HAVE
ANY MAKEUP ON?
>> NATASHA,
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD DO
SUCH A STRONG LIP.
>> DIANA WENT VERY SOFT.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
A MAKEUP CHALLENGE,
WE REALLY NEED YOU TO GO FOR IT.
NOW THE REASON WHY
WE CHOSE THIS PERSON WAS BECAUSE
THEY ACTUALLY USED THE COLORS
VERY WELL,
THEY BLENDED THEM
AND MADE THEM THEIR OWN,
AND SO WE CHOSE...
BRITTANY.
>> COME ON UP HERE.
(applause)
>> GO AHEAD
AND PICK TWO OF YOUR FRIENDS
TO BE IN THE SHOOT WITH YOU.
>> I'M GONNA PICK TWO PEOPLE
BECAUSE THEY WERE THE PEOPLE--
'CAUSE I WAS SICK EARLIER...
>> YOU WERE?
>> THAT TOLD ME TO DO IT ANYWAY.
SO JAEL AND SARAH.
>> AW. YAY!
THAT I'M GOING THROUGH
RIGHT NOW.
>> THE MODELS ARE DOING
A HAIR ACCESSORY STORY,
AND IT'S GONNA SHOWCASE
ALL THE HOTTEST TRENDS
FOR SPRING.
>> I WANT YOUR EYES
JUST UP ABOVE THE CAMERA
RIGHT HERE.
>> BRITTANY TAKES
THE MOST AMAZING PHOTOS
THAT I HAVE EVER SEEN BE TAKEN.
I THINK BRITTANY'S AWESOME,
AND THEY'RE ALL JEALOUS.
>> BRITTANY DOES NOT STAND OUT
TO ME.
SHE'S BORING.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY SHE KEEPS WINNING
THESE CHALLENGES.
IF SHE WANTS TO WIN
ALL THE LITTLE BATTLES
AND I'LL WIN THE BIG WAR,
THAT'LL BE FINE.
I REALLY DON'T CARE.
>> WHOO!
>> THANK YOU.
>> THAT IS A WRAP!
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "'SUNDAE' IS NOT JUST
A DAY OF REST."
"SUNDAE" WAS SPELLED LIKE,
YOU KNOW, ICE CREAM SUNDAE.
>> I BET YOU...
>> OUR PHOTO SHOOT.
>> PHOTO SHOOT.
>> IT'S ICE CREAM.
>> WHOO!
>> YES!
>> MMM.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT'S ALL FAKE?
LIKE, AN ACT?
>> SOME OF THE GIRLS
APPARENTLY SEEM TO THINK
THAT I'M "ACTING" ALL THE TIME
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN GETTING
A LITTLE EMOTIONAL LATELY.
>> IT'S UNREAL.
IT'S UNREAL,
AND I REALLY THINK--
I DON'T BELIEVE HER
AND I DON'T TRUST HER.
>> I DON'T LIKE
CONFRONTING PEOPLE ABOUT THINGS,
BUT I FELT LIKE
I SHOULD SAY SOMETHING.
ARE PAPER-THIN.
THAT'S ALL I GOTTA SAY.
>> OKAY, LISTEN,
I'M JUST GONNA SAY TO YOU
RIGHT NOW,
I HAVE BEEN NOTHING BUT NICE
TO YOU,
NOTHING BUT GENUINE TO YOU.
IT'S NOT LIKE IT'S UNCOMMON
TO HAVE GIRLS TALK ABOUT GIRLS,
AND TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL BAD
ABOUT GOSSIPING
OR ABOUT HAVING A CONVERSATION
ABOUT SOMEBODY ELSE--
FOR ME, IT'S JUST SO PIOUS.
SHE JUST NEEDS
TO COME DOWN OFF HER PEDESTAL.
>> I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
TO SAY TO YOU.
>> RIGHT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, BRITTANY?
YOU BEING 21 YEARS OLD
SURE DO ACT LIKE
YOU'RE STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> I'M STILL KICKING YOUR ASS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪
>> GOD, NO.
>> JAEL IS DEFINITELY HAVING
AN EMOTIONAL DAY TODAY.
WITH THE DEATH OF HER FRIEND,
IT BROUGHT OUT
A LOT OF THOSE EMOTIONS,
WHICH I THINK IS GOOD FOR JAEL.
SHE NEEDS TO REALLY
LET THAT OUT.
>> BUT YOU'RE GONNA BE OKAY.
♪♪♪
>> SHE KEEPS LOOKING AT US
AGAIN.
>> I SWEAR TO GOD, I'M GONNA
KNOCK BRITTANY ON HER ASS
ONE OF THESE TIMES.
>> I CAN'T STAND THE BITCH
EITHER.
>> JAEL NEEDS TO GO THROUGH
WHAT SHE NEEDS TO GO THROUGH,
AND WHAT SHE DOESN'T NEED
IS A BUNCH OF FAKE BITCHES
RUNNING AROUND HER
TRYING TO BE HER FRIEND.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
♪♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING!
>> THIS IS GONNA BE A REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY FUN SHOOT.
ICE CREAM HAPPENS TO BE
ONE OF BOTH TYRA
AND MY FAVORITE TREATS.
AND TODAY
YOU GIRLS ARE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE THE TREATS
IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> YOUR HAIR, MAKEUP, WARDROBE
IS GOING TO BE CANDY.
WHICH MEANS...
YOU'RE GOING TO BE NUDE.
>> YEAH!
>> (cheering)
>> YOU LIKE THAT?
>> (laughs)
>> UH-OH, SOMEONE DOESN'T LOOK
SO EXCITED.
HOW YOU FEELING ABOUT THAT,
UH, BRITT?
>> I'LL DEAL.
>> YOU'LL DEAL? OKAY.
WELL, I AM TOTALLY EXCITED
TO WORK WITH
TODAY'S PHOTOGRAPHER.
YOU PROBABLY HAVE SEEN
A LOT OF HIS WORK.
HE'S EVEN TAKEN
AMAZING SHOTS OF TYRA.
JOSEPH, COME OUT HERE.
>> HEY, GIRLS. HOW YOU DOING?
>> LOOK AT THAT!
SEE, THEY DON'T EVEN CLAP FOR ME
WHEN I WALK IN.
>> YEAH. NICE TO MEET YOU ALL.
>> YOU GUYS REALLY READY
TO DO THIS?
>> YES!
>> (cheering)
>> NO.
I'M UPSET BECAUSE
I KNOW WHEN I GET HOME,
MY PARENTS ARE GOING TO BE
REALLY ANGRY
THAT I TOOK OFF MY CLOTHES,
AND I'M GONNA
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT.
>> ARE YOU OKAY?
>> I DON'T WANT TO DO THIS.
>> BRITTANY WAS NOT
SO COMFORTABLE WITH BEING NUDE--
POUTING AROUND,
ALL THIS LITTLE GIRLIE MESS,
LIKE A LITTLE KID.
I MEAN, BRITTANY, GET OVER IT.
♪♪♪
>> THIS COULD GET MESSY.
>> TAKE THAT SHOULDER
OFF FROM YOUR FACE.
>> DON'T LOSE YOUR NECK.
>> I HAVE COLD ICE CREAM
IN MY HAND,
AND IT WAS REALLY INTENSELY COLD
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO COMPLAIN
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT
TO MAKE A BIG FUSS.
(snarls)
>> SHOULDERS.
>> BRING A LITTLE MORE...
>> (hisses)
>> MORE.
OKAY, NOW THAT'S GOING LIKE,
"HI," AT THE DENTIST.
WHAT CASSANDRA NEEDS TO DO
IS START PRACTICING
IN THE MAKEUP ROOM.
SHE JUST CAME OFF
LOOKING REALLY STIFF.
>> VERY GOOD.
SHOULDERS BACK A LITTLE BIT.
>> I CAN'T FEEL MY HAND ANYMORE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> WHAT?
>> NOBODY'S HAND IS.
>> NOW GIVE ME A LITTLE
GRACE JONES IN THERE.
>> YOU'RE WORKING
THROUGH THE PAIN.
THAT'S PERFECT.
OOH, THAT'S GREAT!
I LIKE THIS SHOOT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
SECOND-GUESSING YOURSELF IN IT.
>> MAYBE I SHOULD JUST
HAVE ICE CREAM IN MY HAND
EVERY SHOOT.
>> WHAT ARE WE DOING ON HER?
>> SHE'S CANDY CANE GIRL.
>> MMM, COOL.
>> PILE ANOTHER ON TOP.
>> DIONNE,
REALLY SELL IT TO ME NOW.
OH, I LOVE THAT!
THAT LITTLE KIND OF "OOH!"
>> (gasps)
>> THAT'S CUTE.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, JAY?
I THINK I'M MORE COMFORTABLE
NAKED.
>> THAT'S, UH... INTERESTING.
>> I'M FREEZING.
THAT'S WHY MY TEETH
ARE CHATTERING.
>> LOOKS GOOD.
I LIKE THE BODY LANGUAGE A LOT.
>> OOH.
>> BRITTANY--SHE WAS JUST EXCUSE
AFTER EXCUSE AFTER EXCUSE.
BUT THEN SHE REALLY ROCKED
HER PHOTO SHOOT.
I JUST WISH
THAT SHE WOULD SHUT UP.
>> LAST FRAME.
GOOD JOB, BRITTANY.
>> LET ME SEE YOUR FACE NOW.
>> HEY, DIANA?
YOU CAN'T LEAN
INTO YOUR STOMACH.
YOU HAVE TO KIND OF LIKE
SUCK IT IN
AND STICK YOUR BOOTY UP.
DIANA IS REALLY INSECURE
WITH WHAT TO DO WITH HER BODY,
AND I THINK DIANA NEEDS
A LITTLE MIRROR TIME, FOR SURE.
EVEN PERFECT BODIES NEED TO...
(makes whooshing sound) SUCK IT
IN WHEN THEY'RE ON CAMERA
TO MAKE THAT... SHAPE COME OUT.
>> I AM NOT THE SIZE OF JASLENE,
WHO HAS, LIKE,
BARELY ANY FAT ON HER BODY.
>> VERY GOOD.
>> SO BASICALLY,
I'M NOT THAT COMFORTABLE,
YOU KNOW, WITH NUDITY.
♪♪♪
>> AND WHO ARE YOU?
>> CANDY NECKLACE.
>> WOW.
>> AW, YEAH.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> OOH, I LOVE THIS, RENEE.
LOOK AT YOU,
THE LITTLE PROFESSIONAL.
OOH, I LOVE THAT.
(claps hands)
>> GOOD JOB, RENEE.
THIS IS BETTER FOR YOU.
WHITNEY, THE POSE LOOKS GREAT.
THE FACE--YOU JUST WANT IT
TO BE A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL.
>> HEAD DOWN A LITTLE BIT.
RIGHT THERE.
>> YOU GOT A GREAT SHAPE, GIRL.
WORK IT.
>> I ABSOLUTELY LOVE CHOCOLATE.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY
THE COLOR OF MY SKIN TONE,
SO I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE HOT,
YOU KNOW,
A LITTLE CHOCOLATE GODDESS.
(laughs)
>> OOH.
>> THAT LOOKS ROCKIN'.
FACE RIGHT TOWARDS ME.
>> LOOK AT YOU HAVING FUN, JAEL.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL, MAN.
>> JAEL WAS HURTING INSIDE,
BUT MASKING IT
BY LAUGHING ABOUT IT
AND MAKING IT OUT TO BE
LIKE EVERYTHING IS A JOKE,
AND SHE'S DOING A GREAT JOB.
>> THAT WAS AMAZING. YOU ROCKED.
>> YEAH?
>> I'M LOVING THE BODY,
BUT I'M MISSING THE FACE, BABY.
>> OKAY.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> (lowers voice) I JUST WANT
A LITTLE MORE EXPRESSION.
>> BOOM. THANKS, LOVE.
>> I WAS DULCE DE LECHE.
I JUST FELT VERY, VERY SENSUAL.
>> WORK YOUR BODY.
GIVE ME SOME SHAPES TO IT.
>> BETTER.
>> YEAH.
>> I LOVE THAT ONE.
>> I KNOW I CAN TAKE
A VERY GOOD PICTURE.
BUT TYRA WAS EMPHASIZING
THE FACT THAT I NEED
TO BRING OUT
MORE OF MY PERSONALITY.
SO I'M HOPING
I'M SHINING THROUGH,
SHOWING THEM THAT I BELONG HERE.
>> LAST FRAME.
OOP.
(blows raspberry)
THIS LOOKS VERY BURLESQUE.
I WAS REALLY THRILLED
TO SEE NATASHA
IMPROVE THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE I REALLY THINK
THERE IS A MODEL
INSIDE OF NATASHA.
>> SHE LOOKS LIKE KATE MOSS.
>> NO, SHE DOESN'T.
DO YOU KNOW WHO KATE MOSS IS?
>> THAT'S HOT, BABE.
>> I FEEL GREAT.
I'M VERY HAPPY
'CAUSE IT WAS REALLY HARD
FOR ME.
BUT I DID IT,
AND I'M VERY PROUD OF MYSELF.
♪♪♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "TOMORROW,
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY TEN OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I MAY BE THE NEXT ONE
TO GO HOME
BECAUSE I WAS LATE
FOR THE MAKEUP CHALLENGE.
>> IT'S REALLY GONNA BE HARD.
I DON'T EVEN WANT TO THINK ABOUT
WHO'S GONNA LEAVE TOMORROW.
>> WELL, I DON'T WANT TO LEAVE.
GOING TO PANEL,
IT'S A LITTLE OVERWHELMING...
>> WHAT DO I DO
WHEN I GET UP THERE?
>> DO YOUR THING.
IF YOU--IF YOU FEEL THE NEED
TO SAY WHAT'S GOING ON,
THEN SAY IT.
IF YOU DON'T,
THEN DON'T SAY ANYTHING.
HEAVENLY FATHER, WE ASK YOU
TO PLACE YOUR HANDS
OF PROTECTION AROUND JAEL.
FATHER GOD, IF THERE IS ANY PAIN
THAT SHE FEELS IN HER HEART,
RELEASE THAT PAIN FROM HER.
LORD, RELEASE IT.
IN YOUR NAME WE PRAY
FOREVER AND EVER, AMEN.
>> AMEN.
>> IT'S OKAY, BABY.
♪♪♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> I KINDA RECOGNIZE YOU GUYS.
BUT SOME, I HAD TO TAKE
A SECOND LOOK
BECAUSE OF THESE MAKEOVERS.
YOU ALL KNOW OUR PRIZES--
A CONTRACT WITH ELITE MODELS,
ONE OF THE TOP MODELING AGENCIES
IN THE WORLD...
A COVER AND A 6-PAGE SPREAD
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE, OUR JUDGES--
MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER...
MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE...
TWIGGY,
FASHION ICON AND LIVING LEGEND
AND NEEKO,
WHO IS THE HAIRSTYLIST
THAT DID ALL OF YOUR MAKEOVERS
OVER AT HIS SALON,
SALON SESSIONS.
>> YAY! THANK YOU.
>> SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE GOING HOME.
JAEL, YOU'RE FIRST.
SO YOU HAD A MAKEOVER THIS WEEK.
YOU LOOK SO MODEL-ICIOUS
RIGHT NOW.
>> YOU WEREN'T TOO EXCITED
WHEN YOU GOT THAT HAIRCUT.
>> I WAS NOT TOO EXCITED.
>> YOU STEPPED UP HERE
LOOKING NERVOUS, UPSET.
>> WHAT'S THE MATTER?
WE TOLD YOU YOU LOOK WONDERFUL.
>> IT'S OKAY, BABY. IT'S OKAY.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> IT'S ALL RIGHT.
>> (crying)
A FRIEND OF MINE PASSED AWAY,
AND--AND I'M...
AND I HAVE--
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME ABOUT IT.
>> OF COURSE YOU'RE HAVING
A HARD TIME ABOUT IT.
>> LIKE, I CAN'T...
I JUST DON'T WANT TO BE A--
HAVE ALL THESE PROBLEMS.
I'M HERE TO BE PROFESSIONAL
AND BE A MODEL.
>> YES, YOU ARE, AND YOU ARE.
>> THIS IS THE ONE TIME
WHEN IT'S OKAY
TO NOT BE A MODEL.
IT'S OKAY TO JUST BE REAL
AND BE A HUMAN BEING.
>> OKAY.
>> WELL, MY SYMPATHY GOES OUT
TO YOU AND TO HER FAMILY
AND TO ALL OF HER FRIENDS,
FOR REAL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I...
(sighs) I REALLY, REALLY WANT
TO BE HERE.
(sighs) OH.
>> ARE YOU READY
TO SHOW YOUR PICTURE?
>> YES, I'D LOVE TO.
>> OOH. OOH!
>> MY GOODNESS, ME. WHAT A SHOT.
>> LET'S SEE A CLOSE-UP.
>> IT'S SO IMPORTANT
TO ENGAGE WITH CAMERA,
AND YOU'VE DONE IT.
>> JAEL,
YOU COMMAND THIS PICTURE.
AND TO BE NAKED AND TO HAVE
THAT LOOK IN YOUR EYES--
THAT'S A TRUE PROFESSIONAL.
>> A LOT OF THE TIMES
I CAN'T RECOGNIZE
YOUR ETHNICITY,
THAT YOU DO HAVE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN IN YOU.
BUT THIS PHOTO--
WE'RE SEEING YOUR ETHNICITY,
WHICH IS GOOD, TO BE ABLE
TO PLAY UP DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> I'D LIKE TO DEDICATE PHOTO
TO MY GIRLFRIEND.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> (sighs)
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> UP NEXT IS NATASHA.
>> OH.
>> SO, NATASHA,
THE ONLY THING IS
WHENEVER YOU GET A MAKEOVER
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT IT IS.
>> CAN WE HAVE A LOOK
AT WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE?
>> IT'S BETTER.
>> THE ONLY THING
IS THIS OUTFIT, NATASHA.
>> TOO MUCH.
>> ALL TOGETHER...
>> JUST A BIT
SHING, SHING, SHING-A-LING.
>> (laughs)
>> HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OH! GORGEOUS.
>> I THINK YOUR EYES
ARE A LITTLE SQUINTY.
>> I LOVE THIS PICTURE ANYWAYS
BECAUSE IT'S SO MUCH BETTER
COMPARED TO OTHER PICTURES
I HAD.
>> YOU ARE THE BEST SALESMAN
IN THE WORLD.
>> UNBELIEVABLE, RIGHT?
>> (laughs)
>> LOOKING AT YOUR FILM--
FOR ME, IT WAS NOT GOOD.
THIS PICTURE IS BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU JUST NEED TO RELAX
AND STOP THINKING.
BEAUTY DOESN'T MAKE A MODEL.
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE ALL THOSE
WEIRD, FUNNY-LOOKING GIRLS,
LIKE, "WHY IS SHE A MODEL?"
BECAUSE SHE KNOWS HOW TO PROJECT
AND BE A MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS FELICIA.
>> OOH.
>> OH, MY GOSH.
>> OH, WOW!
>> SHE KNEW THAT
SHE NEEDED TO DO SOMETHING
TO BE REMEMBERED.
>> (laughs)
>> I LOVE YOUR HAIR,
BUT YOUR OUTFIT
IS WAY TOO VIDEO.
IF YOU HAD THE SAME JEANS ON
AND A STILETTO AND A TANK TOP,
THAT MEANS MORE MODEL.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE HOW YOU DID.
>> OOH, THAT'S MY FAVORITE SHOT
SO FAR.
>> CAN WE SEE A CLOSE-UP?
>> BREATHTAKING.
YOU COMPLETELY COMMAND IT.
>> THE GOOD THING ABOUT YOU
IS THAT YOU'RE GONNA RELATE
TO GIRLS EVERYWHERE
BECAUSE OF YOUR STYLE,
BECAUSE YOU KNOW HOW
TO DO ALL THAT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
YOU NEED TO SOAK UP FASHION
SO THAT YOU KNOW HOW TO DO BOTH.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS WHITNEY.
>> CALL BE BEYONCé. (laughs)
>> GIVE ME A BEYONCé TWIST
AND A TWIRL.
(laughter)
>> LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> GIRL, YOU GOT THIS CREAM
IN ALL THE RIGHT PLACES.
LORD, HAVE MERCY.
>> (laughs)
>> TO ME, IT LOOKS A LITTLE
KIND OF FORCED.
>> YOU LOOK A LITTLE BIT STIFF
AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> YEAH.
>> THE UNCOMFORTABLENESS
THAT EVERYBODY'S FEELING
IS IN YOUR FACE.
IF YOU WOULD'VE DONE
THE SAME STIFF THING
AND WENT LIKE THIS...
IT WOULD'VE CHANGED IT,
INSTEAD OF...
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, WHITNEY.
NEXT IS BRITTANY.
LOOK HOW PRETTY.
>> I THINK THAT COLOR
IS PERFECT ON YOU.
>> IT HURTS SO BAD.
>> YEAH, HAIR WEAVES
ARE SO PAINFUL.
OH, MY GOD.
OH, YOU'RE DOING
THE BLACK GIRL PAT.
YEAH, THAT'S WHAT YOU DO
WHEN YOUR HAIR WEAVE ITCHES.
>> (laughing)
>> YOU WERE
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
>> YEAH.
>> BRITTANY!
>> AND YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY
A VERY FASHIONY SHOT.
>> YEAH.
>> OOH!
>> THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> THIS PICTURE
IS FASHION WEEK 2008.
>> (laughs)
>> NO NEGATIVES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CASSANDRA.
WHOO, TINA TURNER!
>> (laughs)
>> WHAT IS UP WITH THESE SHOES?
>> THE SHOES DON'T WORK.
>> BECOME A CANVAS.
LET US LOOK AT YOU AND SEE YOU.
>> YOU ALL KNOW THIS.
THIS IS "TOP MODEL" CYCLE 8,
Y'ALL.
ALL RIGHT,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
♪♪♪
>> CAN WE LOOK AT THE CLOSE-UP?
SEE, CASSANDRA,
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
IS YOU'VE LOST YOUR NECK.
>> UM, OKAY.
>> STRAIGHT OFF THE BAT,
YOU HEARD THE JUDGING PANEL...
SILENCE.
>> YOU'RE A GIRL THAT KEEPS
CONTINUING TO LOSE YOUR PRETTY.
SO, LIKE, YOU'RE GROWLING
AND YOU'RE LIKE, "AAH! GRR!"
>> IT'S HARD TO STAY PRETTY
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO BE,
LIKE "GRR."
>> BUT YOU'RE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW.
YOU JUST WENT, "GRR,"
INSTEAD OF... (hisses)
>> (laughs) OKAY.
>> YOU NEED TO PRACTICE,
PRACTICE, PRACTICE.
NEXT IS RENEE.
LET'S SEE THAT HAIR,
MESS IT UP A LITTLE BIT.
IT GIVES YOU SOME EDGE.
ALL RIGHT, RENEE,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
I LIKE IT.
IT'S LIKE
ROCKER CANDY NECKLACE GIRL.
>> YES.
THE EYES ARE SLIGHTLY OFF.
>> YOUR EYES
ARE DOING LIKE THIS...
ALMOST THERE,
WHEN YOU SHOULD'VE SAID...
WHERE YOU JUST FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE BURNING
AS OPPOSED TO JUST
KIND OF DOING IT.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS DIONNE.
DIONNE,
WITH SUCH A GREAT HAIRCUT
AND CLOTHES THAT JUST
LOOKS LIKE... OOH, BEYOND MALL.
TAKE YOUR EARRINGS OFF.
TAKE YOUR BELT OFF.
TAKE YOUR SHOES OFF.
TAKE THE BROWN THING OFF.
LOOK AT HER.
>> WAY BETTER.
>> DIFFERENT GIRL.
>> I JUST WISH
YOUR JEANS WERE LONGER.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> GOOD BODY LANGUAGE.
YOU LOOK LONG, TALL, SLIM,
AND LOOK,
YOU'RE HAVING SOME FUN WITH IT.
>> YOU'RE ONE OF THE FEW
WHO HAVE GOT THE FUN SIDE OF IT.
>> UP NEXT IS DIANA.
>> HEY.
>> ANOTHER GIRL
THAT HAS PULLED THAT HAIR BACK
AND WE CAN'T SEE IT.
>> (grunts)
>> THERE YOU GO.
THAT'S SO PRETTY.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> REALLY A VERY BEAUTIFUL FACE.
I'M NOT CRAZY ABOUT
THE LONG SHOT.
>> YOUR POSE IS ACTUALLY
VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE A CENTER OF GRAVITY.
SO YOU SHOULD
PUSH YOUR BOOTY OUT
AND SUCK YOUR STOMACH IN.
>> WHAT SHE SHOULD DO
IS GIVE THEM A COUNT OFF,
THE PHOTOGRAPHER...
>> THAT'S WHAT I DO.
ONE, TWO, THREE...
(inhales sharply)
>> AND DO IT.
>> (exhales deeply)
>> AND THEN--YEAH.
>> I THINK YOU'RE STILL
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
IN HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT YOURSELF.
>> YEAH.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE SO INTROVERTED
IN THIS COMPETITION NOW?
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW.
>> ALL RIGHT, WELL,
MAYBE SOME SELF-REFLECTION.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT IS SARAH,
LOOKING ALL SPRITE AND COOL
WITH YOUR HAIR.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WOW.
FINALLY, SARAH,
YOU'VE BROUGHT IT.
>> YEP, IT'S BRILLIANT.
>> THAT MUCH MAKEUP,
AND YOU SHINE
STRAIGHT THROUGH IT.
>> YES, AND THE EYES CONNECT.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR ALL THE GIRLS
TO LOOK AT HER EYES,
ESPECIALLY RENEE.
YOU WERE KIND OF THERE,
BUT THIS IS ALL THE WAY THERE.
JASLENE. WHY DON'T YOU
THICKEN IT UP A BIT?
LOOK AT THAT, BEAUTIFUL.
AND SO MUCH EARRINGS, JASLENE.
YOU JUST CAN'T HELP YOURSELF.
>> (laughs)
>> SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> THE CAMERA
ABSOLUTELY LOVES YOU.
>> YOU'VE GOT
A GREAT EXPRESSION.
THAT'S GOT TO BE
THE MOST COMFORTABLE SHOT,
I THINK, OF THE ENTIRE BUNCH.
BUT I DON'T SEE YOU, THE MODEL,
RIGHT HERE.
>> THE--THE PHOTOGRAPH AND YOU
DON'T ALWAYS GO TOGETHER.
>> WHEN I GO HOME AT NIGHT,
I REMEMBER JAEL,
I REMEMBER CERTAIN GIRLS,
BUT I DON'T REMEMBER JASLENE.
>> BUT BACK AT HOME,
I'M A REAL CHA-CHA.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
CULTURE IS BEAUTIFUL.
I DON'T SIT UP HERE AND GO,
"THAT WAS A GREAT SHOT."
I'M LIKE,
"GIRL, YOU BETTER WORK IT.
DA-DA-DA. YOU LOOK-A HOOCHIE."
THAT'S MY CULTURE.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO, LIKE,
BRING THAT.
ALL RIGHT, JASLENE, THANK YOU.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND AFTER THAT,
I WILL CALL YOU BACK
AND ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
♪♪♪
>> NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH ONE OF THESE GIRLS
SHOULD GO HOME.
JAEL.
>> IT'S REALLY TRAGIC
WHAT'S HAPPENED TO HER,
BUT THIS PICTURE OF JAEL IS
THE BEST ONE I'VE SEEN OF HER.
>> NATASHA.
>> I'M NOT SURE
THE CAMERA LOVES HER
AS MUCH AS WE LOVE HER
IN PERSON.
>> SHE'S STILL TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE TIME
FOR HER TO FIGURE IT OUT.
WHITNEY.
>> WHITNEY IS
REALLY A PRETTY GIRL,
BUT SHE'S NOT MODEL PRETTY.
>> I SEE HER SINGING IN A CHOIR.
I DON'T SEE HER AS A TOP MODEL.
>> HELL TO THE NO!
WHITNEY IS JUST FIERCE AS SHE IS
AND Y'ALL ARE JUST HATIN'.
(normal voice) DIONNE.
>> FINALLY,
SHE'S SORT OF SEPARATING HERSELF
FROM THE PACK, AND--AND I THINK
DIONNE'S ONE TO WATCH.
>> JASLENE.
>> I MEAN,
SHE'S PICTURE-PERFECT,
PRETTY MUCH, WEEK AFTER WEEK.
>> MMM.
>> IT'S JUST THE PERSONALITY,
WHICH IS NOT THERE.
>> SHE ALWAYS DISAPPEARS
FOR ME OUT THERE.
SHE COMES TO LIFE
IN A PHOTOGRAPH.
>> SARAH.
>> LOOK AT SARAH'S EYES--
COMPLETELY STRAIGHT AT YA.
THEY'RE BURNING THROUGH YOU.
>> RENEE.
>> I ACTUALLY QUITE LIKE
THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK IT'S VERY EDGY.
IT'S VERY QUIRKY.
>> SHE HAS, LIKE,
REALLY FLIRTY EYES WITH ME.
>> SHE HAS FLIRTY EYES WITH ME.
CASSANDRA.
IF THERE'S A SUCH THING
AS BEAUTIFUL PERSONALITY
COMING FROM WITHIN, THAT IS HER.
>> AND I DON'T THINK
SHE KNOWS WHAT TO DO
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
>> I JUST DON'T SEE
MODEL POTENTIAL HERE,
AND IT'S POTENTIAL THAT WE NEED.
>> BRITTANY.
>> THIS IS
A HIGH-FASHION PHOTOGRAPH
WITHOUT A STITCH OF CLOTHING ON.
I MEAN, IT'S BRILLIANT.
>> SHE'S ALWAYS ON THE VERGE
OF MODEL TEARDROPLETS.
(imitates crying)
>> (laughs)
>> DIANA.
>> SHE'S ONE OF
THE PRETTIER GIRLS.
I THINK SHE COULD BE
A LOT SEXIER,
SHE COULD USE HER CURVES.
SHE COULD WORK HER BODY,
AND SHE DOESN'T.
>> FELICIA.
>> WHAT SHE PROBABLY WATCHES
IN THE MUSIC VIDEOS IS
KIND OF LIKE WHAT SHE'S BECOME.
>> WATCH
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> NOT "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
HIP-HOP BOOTY SHAKIN' STAR."
>> (laughs)
♪♪♪
>> 11 OF YOU STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY
I ONLY HAVE TEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE TEN GIRLS
ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
BRITTANY.
>> EXCUSE ME.
>> THIS PICTURE IS STUNNING.
THE JUDGES ARE IN LOVE WITH IT.
I JUST WISH YOU LUCK
WITH YOUR WEAVE.
>> ALL RIGHT. (laughs)
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
JAEL.
JAEL, THIS PICTURE IS BEAUTIFUL.
AND AS YOU SAID,
THIS PICTURE
IS DEDICATED TO HER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
SARAH.
CONGRATULATIONS.
DIONNE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> FELICIA.
(laughter)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> RENEE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> WHITNEY.
>> (exhales deeply) WHEW.
>> THESE JUDGES KEEP ON SAYING
THEY'RE NOT SURE
IF YOU ARE A MODEL.
DON'T THINK PAGEANT.
THINK HIGH FASHION.
NATASHA.
>> THANKS, TYRA.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL IS...
JASLENE.
DO YOU KNOW WHY YOU WERE CALLED
SO CLOSE TO LAST?
>> PERSONALITY?
>> MM-HMM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
WILL DIANA AND CASSANDRA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> DIANA...
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
AND FOR YOU TO BE ONE OF
THE VOLUPTUOUS, SEXY GIRLS,
YOU SHOULD BE STANDING OUT
SO STRONGLY.
BUT THE JUDGES JUST FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE KIND OF FADING
INTO THE BACKGROUND.
AND CASSANDRA...
BEAUTIFUL PERSONALITY.
AND I HEAR THAT YOU'RE THE GIRL
THAT GIVES ALL OF THESE GIRLS
STRENGTH HERE,
THAT GIVES THEM
PEACE AND SPIRITUALITY.
AND THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT I LOOK AT IN A MODEL.
BUT AS WELL-ROUNDED AS YOU ARE,
WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT
ON A PHOTO.
SO WHO GOES HOME--
THE PRETTY GIRL
WHO TAKES NICE PHOTOS
BUT THE JUDGES
HAVE A HARD TIME REMEMBERING
AND DON'T FEEL A SPARK?
OR THE GIRL
WITH THE HEART OF GOLD,
BEAUTIFUL ON THE INSIDE AND OUT,
BUT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
ON A PICTURE YET?
>> DIANA.
>> (crying)
♪♪♪
>> (sniffles)
>> IT'S A PRETTY PICTURE,
BUT IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THAT,
IS IT?
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
YOU KEEP PRACTICING YOUR PICTURE
AND YOUR POSIN'.
>> OKAY, I WILL.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU'RE GONNA MAKE ME CRY.
>> (crying) GOD.
WE LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
>> OH, GOD.
>> OH...
(speaks indistinctly)
BYE.
I'LL MISS EVERYBODY.
THEY TOTALLY TOUCHED MY HEART.
I'M DISAPPOINTED BECAUSE
I KNOW THAT I HAVE POTENTIAL
TO BE A TOP MODEL.
I FEEL SAD
TO HAVE LEFT SO EARLY
IN THE COMPETITION.
BUT I NEED MORE MIRROR TIME
AND I NEED TO PRACTICE MORE.
I WISH I WOULD'VE JUST
GAVE MORE CONFIDENCE
AND MORE FIERCENESS
TO THE CAMERA.
BUT I'M STILL APPRECIATIVE
FOR WHAT I DID GET,
BECAUSE MANY GIRLS
DON'T EVEN GET THIS.
>> COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
>> THIS IS YOUR CHALLENGE.
>> OH!
>> THE GIRLS ATTEMPT
A CHALLENGING BANK HEIST
TO WIN AN UNBELIEVABLE PRIZE.
>> (laughs)
>> AND RENEE REACHES
HER BREAKING POINT.
>> (crying) I CAN'T STAND
THESE GIRLS, JASON.
I SWEAR TO GOD, I'M GONNA...
BEAT THEM ALL... DOWN.
♪♪